this afternoon after 10 months in court
the 14 defendants arrived to hear the
verdicts escorted by heavy security
it was the conclusion of the largest
trial in modern french history after one
of the worst terror attacks in peacetime
europe
on the evening of the 13th of november
2015
nine gunmen and suicide bombers launched
coordinated attacks within minutes of
each other at the bataclan concert hall
the stad de france and crowded
restaurants across paris
130 people were killed and hundreds were
injured in the hours that followed
european intelligence agencies worked
closely together to find encompasses to
this terror network and the one
surviving attacker salah abdeslam
abdeslam went on the run and a
continental manhunt was launched
he was identified in this cctv with
another suspect who had connections to
the attacks muhammad abrini this was
filmed just days before the paris
attacks
it was believed abduslam had moved
around paris with the attackers that
night with the intention of using his
own suicide vest
he didn't detonate it though instead he
dumped the vest in a bin and escaped
paris
months later he was arrested in belgium
in the same district where he'd grown up
and been radicalized
at the start of the trial abduslam was
unrepentant when asked he gave his
profession as islamic state fighter but
in recent weeks he's changed his tone
even pleading for clemency saying that
the reason he did not explode his
suicide vest was because he wanted to
save lives
but the police disagree with that they
say that when they found it it was
defective and that is the only reason he
didn't blow himself up
archeo denver survived the attack on the
bataclan and like the police and
prosecution doubts abdassalam's recent
statements he feels very apologetic but
i think he's apologetic towards himself
he's mad at himself for getting into
that and
either going into that or not going the
whole way
and getting in that middle ground where
he'll be in jail for probably the rest
of his life
absalom smirked when he heard the
sentence he's received france's harshest
punishment the 32 year old would die in
prison some small justice for the
victims
it's kind of relief because then
the the trial is done now but it's it's
just the end of one step and we have to
continue to i mean you would never
forget what happened
with the memories of that knife yeah
definitely not yeah i mean for sure i
mean it's it's there so i mean the worst
thing and i told that to my brother is
that now they are in our heads so
and it's exactly that seven years after
they're still there and
yeah the court did they did their job
perfect and now it's our own job to
continue to recover
the victims their families and the
french nation have waited seven years
for justice
outwardly paris is its buzzy
cosmopolitan normal self once more
but the night of the 13th of november
2015 will forever be etched in the
city's history
alisa bunkel sky news in paris